it started in solidarity and song to
keep up spirits now after three weeks of
lockdown the mood and dangers are
apparently evolving they are no longer
singing or dancing on the balconies now
people are more afraid not so much of
the virus but of poverty many are out of
work and hungry even though in the
poorest southern regions the impact of
Kovach 19 has been less dramatic than in
the north they too are in confinement
and as people run out of food and money
so does patients as residents are
becoming desperate
police are now patrolling supermarkets
and streets in some areas no longer just
to make sure that people are staying
indoors but to stop thieves we need to
act fast more than fast distress could
turn into violence as supplies dry up
reports are emerging that gangs around
Sicily are using social media to plot
attacks on stores this comes after a
ferry company that used to deliver vital
supplies of food and medicine to the
island fell into bankruptcy and has
halted its services it's not just the
stores that are under threat
local media has also reported that two
elderly Italians were robbed of their
shopping by young people on scooters
targeted apparently because they were
seen as easy prey civil unrest is some
suggest a real concern I'm afraid that
the worries that are affecting large
sections of the population over health
income on the future with the
continuation of the crisis will turn
into anger unhe 'tried that warning has
been echoed by the head of the Red Cross
which believes Italy won't be the only
country impacted by social unrest
if the lockdowns continue in the most
difficult neighborhoods of the biggest
cities I'm afraid that in a few weeks we
will have social problems this is a
social bomb that can explai
at any moment because they don't have
any way to have an income even though
Italy's Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte
has said his government will designate
four hundred million euros for food
vouchers as part of a wider relief
package may say that the funds simply
aren't enough we were expecting more and
I hope the government will find a way
the situation is extremely delicate as a
significant part of the population has
zero income those who before lived with
dignity now find themselves in
difficulty quarantine in Italy has been
extended until at least April the 12th
but as with other countries that is not
a definitive end date and while kovat 19
may be gutting the country italy soon
could have to fight back against a very
different kind of threat sholat Dubinsky
RT paris
you